okay here we go one is plenty for you
can go for the zillion c3m not the most
entertaining move ever they don't have
something really nice here I go for this
offbeat move Queen air five it's a bit
bit strange looking of course but maybe
it's not so bad I don't know details of
course ooh 93 young Nancy fourth course
make some sense this one maybe I don't
know this is all all made up here
yeah it didn't it doesn't look so bad
when I'd see if I can just go back to c7
ok tries to to open it up immediately
now maybe this one to exchange one night
ok now come just a three to get rid of
the pin how to tell you but I want to
get rid of the e5 Knight ok I'm very
much behind in development still it's
interesting what should I do now maybe
just just e62 to catch up the BTM I've
got the t two bishops after all which is
nice ok I think I need to go back here
came we should be seven
yeah I think I can just cancel okay hmm
okay just just take here now I'm even
better developed at least a bit because
okay interesting
not sure if is get some got some really
good discoveries here still I'd like to
get all of this
yeah maybe you try for Queen g3
something like this could be an idea
maybe I can play rook e8 order to
prepare f6 to get rid of the night
that's a bit inconvenient here ok ok ok
let's try exchange some pieces ok he's
obviously happy to to get rid of my
bishop pair the Sun should be a no
problem for me here should be just equal
maybe Bishop f6 would have been better
but not sure I might have literally five
not hmm how can I can just play at 6am
ok yeah this should be it should be ok
in terms of equality ok know what what
is supposed to mean Quincy 70 what's the
idea maybe
yeah maybe
play rook c8 you might go queen d 7 cats
on you too I need to just play okay here
okay maybe this one to let him exchange
on c6 I think that it's no big deal if
he gets to d7 yeah this is no no big
problem i think i have less time as
usual okay need to lead some area
I might go Brooke a seven rupees have
not something like this
let's grab some space okay
time warning yes usual my time
management wasn't really great can you
to prevent him getting two rooks on the
7th so 0 p 7 now you can have one that's
no big deal
still cannot do much here
yeah I feel at home might be weak but I
am get some some play here
check-check
k is going to be porn
I can try to take the other points
though
yeah but I get a lot of points now him
okay this is a winning look end game
when f 12 seconds though check check
check mmm just just too quick okay this
was lucky of course check check white
forfeits on time yeah i did a better
move here in the time pressure check
this was ridiculous of course just just
go rook rook t5 here to get the winning
bridge done yeah well okay this was just
a nothing game which has been ended in a
draw somehow he allowed me to to get to
get get here and this was just bad just
that play in time troll yeah how did the
opening and so it was just just equal